all right Denise stepping into the
housewives world's are you ready for
this wild ride
yeah and it is a wild ride it's a lot of
fun so the big news tonight was
Vanderpump showed up and then left
immediately what do you make of that did
she show up really early they showed up
and she left it mister I know she left a
question for everybody and it's just why
why yeah why that's a good question I
think you should awesome what's your
response to why she has a question why
yeah I yeah why not come back and hang
out with us if you had to sum up your
housewives experience with one word
what's the word to describe it fine
I had a lot of fun really good your name
has been floated around for year after
year after year of like Denise might get
on this show what was it about now you
know I think the timing was right and if
I'm gonna do a show like this I would
want to be my true authentic self and be
really honest and open and I'm in a
great place to do that and so I thought
why not just have fun with it
I loved your People magazine spread
sharing Eloise's story
why was now the time to do that well
because it came up on the show and
people watching I haven't seen any other
episode except the first one would you
know see different things about her and
it's so obviously I had talked about it
and I imagine the response has been
pretty amazing I was so like touched at
how supportive and really wonderful
everyone has been and sharing their
stories and bringing it out in the open
so it was really pretty incredible all
right final question we also had
everybody leave a question for the next
person Rinna left you playing off
Vanderpump she said why ask her why just
why she knows why and just for
Valentine's Day we're asking everybody
how they met so how did you and Arin me
get in here Aaron
because a hubby is complicated it's
complicated we met at his Center they'll
be revealed later yes I was a client
your whole business with pleasure this
is your whole love story play on the
show so we'll watch that yeah thank you
thank you
enjoy the ride thank you so much
[Music]